well it is just an extension of the
diary and there is a wonderful book
called the assassins cloak which takes
diary entries from all centuries and
arranged them according to day of the
year so you can turn to January the
first and there will be an entry from
Lord Byron and there will be one from
somebody during World War two and there
will be one from brian eno and then on
january the second there will be
somebody else but people used to perform
their their lives this way to themselves
in their diaries and also through
letters to other people so for me
anything that happens in social media is
an extension of stuff we were already
doing in some other way so it's all
human communication and the form that
most closely resembles the tweet is the
telegram of old which also was limited
because you paid by the letter and short
communications very rapidly sent so all
of these things the postal service etc
they're all improvements if you like or
or modernizations of things that already
existed earlier in some other form even
African tribal drums for instance could
send very complex messages over great
distances they were very rapid they were
very well worked out and communications
could just go like wildfire using that
using that meeting and move of
communication so all of the stuff it's
what we do now but it's not different in
nature from what we have always done
which is communicate with one another
send messages to one another and perform
our lives we've been doing that for a
long time
it's very interesting once upon a time
in social life say before the 19th
century people coated themselves or were
coated by the authorities according to
their clothing unless they
differentiated themselves that way or
they were differentiated people were
forbidden to wear this about it the
other thing and they had to wear this or
that or the other thing and therefore it
was a it was a visual performance for
the benefit of anybody looking at them
and we have reduced clothing I think to
a much more horizont weave it's much
more horizontal you can't tell by
looking at somebody what level of
society they come from unless it's
really at the bottom or really at the
top the kind of jeans and the jeans
outfit is pretty ubiquitous so maybe we
feel the need to perform ourselves in
some other way and if you think that
what goes up on people's blogs is really
the full content of their lives of
course you're quite wrong it's what
they're doing in the spotlight it's
their turn and they-- the spotlight they
can shine it on themselves they can go
in there and sort of dance about and
create a persona for themselves but of
course it's not the whole story